this podcast has bad words
what if your spouse is not on board with
minimalism and it causes conflict
the first thing that comes to mind for
nicola's question is the acronym that we
use tara
so it stands for tolerate respect
appreciate and this is kind of josh and
i's way
of helping people with any tumultuous
relationship not just with
you know couples who wants a minimalist
and one is not a minimalist this is with
friends family anyone that you care
deeply about in your life that you want
to have a good relationship
this acronym is going to help you so
much so the first step
is tolerate it's a pretty weak virtue
right when you're out in traffic
especially in la someone cuts me off
it's like
i want to get mad i want to honk my horn
and you know give him a
a specific gesture and i i tell myself
like dude that's la
like it's a lot of people i this person
maybe they're having a bad day maybe
they're you know maybe their
wife's giving birth right now in the
passenger seat or something like i try
to give them the benefit of the doubt
and what that does is it helps me
tolerate
that person so i'm not going to be
friends with that person i'm not going
to go out of my way to hang out with
them but i will tolerate
their actions accepting
well actually what i just said about
that that thought process i go through
it helps me get to acceptance because
i remember when i first moved to los
angeles i tried to follow all the
traffic laws
i'm like i'm not going to run red lights
i'm not gonna do illegal u-turns i'm
gonna like
you know i'm gonna because in missoula
it's like it's pretty easy to follow all
the traffic laws but what i realized
was that in la if you follow the traffic
laws you actually impede traffic
you're actually hurting you're not you
know it's me virtue signaling i will not
run this red light well i'm screwing up
the rest of the traffic
in certain cases so i've accepted the
circumstances that i'm in
and uh i've moved on from there respect
i guess let's keep going with the
traffic thing
like i respect the fact that there are
20 or
12 million people in la county there's a
lot of people
and like we're all trying to live our
lives we're all we all have friends and
family we love
we're all trying to get a good meal
we're all trying to you know be happy
we're all trying to find our way for joy
and i can respect the fact that really
all of us
on on a very deep level all pretty much
want the same
things now some people go about it
differently uh i feel like there's a lot
of entitlement
especially when it comes to driving
although i'll tell you i got
hit but there was this guy who hit me
i think it was a mustang or no it was a
dodge charger whatever it was it was
like one of those like you know
kind of middle middle range uh fast
sports
fast cars yeah fancy loud cars yeah the
fast and furious kind
it was real loud was it vin diesel i
wish
i would have just thought i was just
like just keep on going man i'll take
care of this
so this this guy was weaving in and out
of traffic
and my instinct was like oh this guy's a
jerk he's probably a douche bag
and like you know like all these insults
start popping up in my head and i start
judging this person
about what they're doing and then uh it
didn't really pay him much attention
uh i went to go i was i changed the lane
and right after i changed the lane he
changed the lane and like basically ran
right into my back
bumper because he just wasn't paying
attention wasn't a good driver
uh long story short he got out of it we
pulled over got out of the car he was
like
the nicest most calm
person and he was like oh i'm so sorry
like is your wife okay and he goes over
to mariah
honey are you okay i'm so he's like this
car it's so because i was like oh this
is a nice car he's like oh he's like if
you had to drive this car
he's like you would hate it he's like i
i bought this car because i thought it
was gonna like you know be cool make me
happy you know he's telling me why
he's like but i hate driving this car
it's and he goes in la
he's like traffic is so stressful man
he's like it stresses me out so bad to
be in traffic in la
and i it helped me just respect that
person a little bit differently
and uh just look at him and then now i'm
at a point which is the last
letter in the acronym is appreciate i
can actually appreciate
again going with the traffic the way los
angeles
is like there is a way that la has to be
in order for it to function
with 12 million people in its county so
i have gotten to a level of appreciation
so
you can do this with other people you
have to do this with a city in a traffic
like
that's just the most benign example i
could think of right but if you have a
person in your
life that you're having a hard time
getting with just start with tolerance
and then how can you start to accept
them for who they are how can you even
go out of your way to show respect and
maybe
just maybe you can even appreciate who
they are as a person so this isn't about
making your spouse a minimalist
right this is about loving them and if
you use that acronym tara like you
can get you that's how you show someone
that you love them one of the problems
is you want your spouse to be a
minimalist right
yeah and so step one stop wanting to
change someone
right and and so one of the things that
we often do when we want
that is we try to how do we try to
change and we convince them
that my point of view is either better
or maybe it's just right
and that's when the self-righteousness
comes in and what you're talking about
this terror
is the antidote to self-righteousness
ooh yeah because you're tolerating them
that's a
decent first step it's not to get you
very far tolerance doesn't do much for
you right right
it helps you go on your day without
losing your mind
yes if you stay stuck in tolerance
you're going to be miserable though
that's why you have to transcend that
and eventually get to the appreciation
now you can do that with traffic
you can do that with your partner but
more importantly you can do that with
their
horde right earlier in this maximal
episode we were talking about
hoarding versus archiving versus
collecting and how most collecting is
well
planned hoarding and
yet we also talked about how my
horde could be a collection for someone
else
and by letting go but the opposite is
also true
just because you view your partner's
things as a horde because you don't see
them as particularly useful
to you well that doesn't mean
they're not useful or beautiful or
awe-inspiring or
augmenting or amplifying or life
enhancing
to your significant other and
when we can respect that then we can
start respecting the individual things
it's like
a guitar if you if mariah had a guitar
and you didn't play guitar you wouldn't
say well that's stupid why do you play
guitar that's
the wrong thing to do you could actually
appreciate that pretty quickly yeah it's
harder when it becomes a when it's a
figurine or
a sewing kit or a dress collection or
whatever it might be
it becomes more difficult now
fundamentally i will say this
you and your partner have different
preferences now that's an obvious
statement that's true with
everyone even bex and i who are so
similar
in terms of our personalities
we have different preferences we have
different ideas of what
tidy is even and that's okay
now we've set up some boundaries in our
own home we don't bring any
we've agreed together this is not my
rule it's not her rule we came up with
this together
we've agreed we don't bring anything new
into our home unless we've both
said we're going to bring it into the
home right
we've also agreed we're not going to get
rid of each other's items
i can get rid of all of my own things i
can get down
buck naked and own zero items
and she'll be fine with that yeah she
might not be okay if i'm just
yeah that's that's the other side of the
insanity thing you were talking about
earlier
but i could get down to owning
functionally nothing
sure she'd be fine with that yeah but
it's not about me then determining
she needs to live and our daughter ella
needs to live
with functionally nothing right i can
tend
to my own garden and maybe if that
garden is beautiful and fruitful enough
she's going to do something similar with
her garden
as well yeah absolutely by the way
by the way uh nicola you can find that
tara acronym
and love people use things and there's a
whole
story in here about how you can begin to
tolerate
your spouse's stuff
uh their collection and maybe even their
horde
so we talk a bit about that recognizing
you have different preferences as long
as you have similar
values you'll be able to work that
acronym
together now if your values are
different you want to get clear on your
values there's a values worksheet in the
back of the book
as well man talking about our book
it like really i have to bring myself
back to that orlando meetup we did the
very first
orlando meetup we did and there was like
you know it was the couchsurfers that
were there yeah i think it was our was
it our fourth tour stop or second tour
stop ever
second tour stop yeah and i just felt
i didn't want to sell my book right i'm
like one of the minimalists like i can't
sell my book right there there was
something that was like blocking me up
with that
and so i was always like really
trepidatious with um
talking about the book is that i want to
feel like i'm just trying to sell
someone something
um but one of the uh one of the men that
was that were there he's like hey man do
you really believe in what
you guys wrote i'm like yeah he's like
do you think it's actually going to like
help people i'm like yeah of course
he's like then be proud of what you
wrote man and he's like there's no shame
in like trying to share something with
someone there's a monetary berry
a barrier that's okay yeah of course
yeah so
uh but it's funny because like i still
have to remind myself of that because we
talk about our books so much but like
dude this might be the best thing we've
ever written man and it's three years
of of you know pouring our guts onto a
page
not knowing if it's going to work
because i wrote about this toward the
end it's like
there were four false starts with with
the next book whatever it was going to
be
until we finally figured out the path
that we wanted to take with this book
and it wasn't a traditional relationship
book it was a relationship book
and it was really a book about healing
in a way and and so it's not about
fixing yourself you're not a machine
it's about healing and what does healing
do it does leave behind scars those
scars are some phenomenal stories and
you get to see
some of our scars in fact you get to see
the open wounds before they turned into
healing for us in in that book did you
enjoy this video
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel
100 percent advertisement free